buonasera a tutti spero che siate ancora
abbastanza svegli ci siete più o meno si
pronti perfetto allora questa sera è una
meravigliosa serata io ringrazio tutti i
gli speakers come si dice che hanno
parlato prima di me perché mi hanno
permesso di prendere tanti spunti che
poi porteremo qui anche in questo mio
speech come succede se una volta una
relazione che sono specie allora l'idea
di base è quella di cui vi voglio
parlare oggi è cambiare paradigma il
mondo e la rivoluzione quantistica
allora quando noi parliamo di un
paradigma dobbiamo parlare di qualcosa
che ci troviamo dentro qualcosa che è
insito in noi qualcosa che ci accompagna
da quando studiamo lavoriamo conosciamo
le contaminazioni positive come quella
che è nata questa sera servono proprio
per cambiare il paradigma per farsi
vedere nuove realtà nuove visioni del
mondo
nuove prospettive perché rimanere sempre
ancorati a quello che c'era
precedentemente a quello che già
conosciamo non è mai una strategia
vincente
neanche dal punto di vista evolutivo e
ve lo dimostrerò grazie alla storia
della fisica
quest'uomo che vedete davanti a voi è in
realtà lord kelvin
ma il suo vero nome è lord william
thompson primo barone di kelvin lo
conosciamo tutti perché è l'ideatore
della scala di kelvin la scala della
temperatura ebbene quest'uomo che qui
vedete ritratto è un dipinto dalla fine
dell'ottocento era uno dei più grandi
scienziati di quell'epoca e nel 1000
e novecento nel settembre del 1900 da
vanti alla british association for the
advancement of science
l'associazione britannica per
l'avanzamento della scienza disse una
frase strepitosa disse ormai in fisica
non c'è più nulla da scoprire tutto ciò
che rimane da realizzare sono misure
sempre più precise in gergo potremmo
dire che aveva toccato perché beh perché
da lì a un mese sarebbe successo
qualcosa di assolutamente imprevisto e
imprevedibile
eppure questa non era un'idea che aveva
solo lui
albert michaelson premio nobel nel 1907
perché stiamo parlando di grandi geni
disse nel 1894 che era idea diffusa che
ormai tutto quello che c'era da scoprire
era già stato scoperto eppure come tante
altre previsioni si è dimostrato tutto
infondato vi faccio un altro esempio
sempre il nostro lord kelvin nel 1895
disse la seguente frase nessuna macchina
più pesante dell'aria potrà mai volare
avete presente gli aeroplani gli
elicotteri quelle cose lì oppure nel
1899 disse presto verrà dimostrato che i
raggi ics sono tutta una truffa 1901
premio nobel harold che proprio per la
scoperta dei raggi ics allora cosa
succede ad un certo punto succede che in
quella frase che abbiamo visto un attimo
fa è insita una realtà molto molto
profonda
una realtà considerata tale
cioè che la natura fosse continua non è
una cosa da poco pensare che la natura
se continua qualcosa che ci appartiene
perché noi vediamo gli oggetti continui
li vediamo davanti a noi così come sono
e crediamo che siano così ma nel ottobre
la notte fra il 7 ottobre del 1900
succede qualcosa di assolutamente
incredibile
vedete quest'uomo quest'uomo e max
planck un altro premio nobel per la
fisica nel 1918 bene quest'uomo quella
notte scopre una legge lui sta studiando
una particolare radiazione un fenomeno
che in fisica si chiama radiazione di
corpo nero sta cercando di descrivere
l'energia associata a una radiazione
elettromagnetica non riesce a farla ci
sono varie varie vari tentativi varie
prove per riuscire a descrivere questa
legge
poi in quella notte lui scrive una
formula semplicissima scrive che
l'energia è uguale a una costante quella
che noi chiamiamo costante di planck ha
il suo onore adesso moltiplicata per la
frequenza della radiazione
elettromagnetica
ma questa formula dentro di sé a una
rivoluzione incredibile a un cambio di
paradigma mostruoso per che cosa dice
dice che l'energia e quantizzata quindi
neanche un mese dopo le affermazioni di
lord kelvin e si scopre che la realtà e
quantizzata l'energia e quantizzata e
questo non è un caso non è un esempio
semplice perché cambia completamente il
paradigma cambia completamente la realtà
tanto vero che due grandi geni che sono
albert einstein che vedete è di fianco a
lui lui deboli
entrambi i premi nobel naturalmente
beh cosa possono fare einstein nel 1905
studiando un effetto che si chiama in
fisica effetto fotoelettrico trova i
fotoni cioè i quanti della luce una
scoperta incredibile prima blanc trova e
quanti dell'energia einstein nel 1905
trova i quanti della luce verranno
chiamati fotoni un paio di anni dopo e
nel 1924 lui dei progetti all'epoca
aveva 32 anni
cosa fa
scopre anzi prima ipotizza poi viene
dimostrata che le particelle possono
avere una natura ondulatoria cioè mette
ancora più in crisi per paradigma perché
ci dice non solo che la natura e
quantizzata ma che una particella che
noi consideriamo corpus colata con
diventa una può essere rappresentata e
una radiazione elettromagnetica capite
che salti che ci sono beh se non si
fosse cambiato questo paradigma se non
fossimo arrivati alla quantizzazione
molto di quello che noi vediamo adesso
non sarebbe possibile e in particolare
qualcosa che ci riguarda tutti ma è solo
per fare un esempio quello che vedete
alle mie spalle e una slide fatta al
cern all open lab
da federico carminati che il chief
innovation
del del cern e insomma e dell'opel la
del cem che rappresenta che cosa
rappresenta come funzionano i computer
quantistici
non si può parlare dei computer
quantistici senza parlare di realtà
quantistica e non si può parlare dei
computer quantistici senza far
riferimento a quella frase che vedete
scritta in alto sulla vostra destra la
natura e quantistica dannazione l'unico
modo in cui possiamo rappresentarla e
dissimularla tramite che cosa abbiamo
bisogno di un computer quantistico
e questa frase è stata detta da feinmann
altro premio nobel nel 1982 nel 1981
alle miti ma non è solo il cambio di
paradigma è anche la contaminazione che
c'è dietro perché dalla fisica teorica
siamo arrivati all'informatica alla
tecnologia alla meccanica e ancora più
avanti perché certe volte cambiare
paradigma vuol dire avere un coraggio
che va al di là di quello che noi stessi
possediamo vedete questa foto sono due
grandi geni albert einstein che
conosciamo e niels bohr albert hai
sempre meno belle nel 1921 niels bohr
prime nobel nel 1922 bene erano grandi
amici entrambi lavoravano alla fisica
quantistica la meccanica quantistica ma
ad un certo punto einstein mette in
discussione la fisica quantistica
nel senso che non la ritiene più una
teoria completa e fa insieme a due altri
scienziati che sono podolski e roczen un
articolo nel quale dice il titolo
esattamente questo può alla descrizione
della natura della fisica quantistica
considerarsi completa e che cosa dice la
risposta è no perché ancorato allo
stesso paradigma che lui ha creato e per
lui la
quantistica prevede delle implicazioni
assolutamente sconvolgente
una di queste implicazioni e che due
particelle che entrano in contatto fra
di loro rimangono collegate in qualche
maniera anche se poste a distanza di
tempo e di spazio molto molto molto
grandi e lo fanno in maniera istantanea
cioè se cambio qualcosa nella prima
particella cambio qualcosa
automaticamente nella seconda e questo
contraddice la relatività e contraddice
molte altre regole e allora in sta
invece non è possibile
bene non è talmente possibile che nel
1982 alain aspect che lui riesce a
dimostrare questo fenomeno
un fenomeno che noi tutti adesso
conosciamo e al quale diamo il nome di
entanglement implicazione l'entanglement
quantistico esiste c'è ma lo stesso
einstein insieme a podolski roczen aveva
detto che non era possibile
abbiamo dovuto cambiare un'altra volta
il paradigma abbiamo dovuto un'altra
volta a riconsiderare tutto quello che
abbiamo fatto per scoprire qualcosa che
adesso utilizziamo e utilizziamo
tantissimo tant'è vero che l'istituto di
fotonica di barcellona e questa è una
sua immagine che è uno dei principali
luoghi al mondo dove si studiano le
implicazioni del lentamente a vari
laboratori vari al filoni di ricerca dal
teletrasporto quantistico delle
informazioni fino alla metrologia
quantistica cioè l'applicazione delle
logiche dell entanglement per lo studio
delle misure sempre più piccole non solo
l'intricato né quantistica è utile
persino per sincronizzare gli orologi
atomici o addirittura per una branca
particolare dell'informatica la
crittografia quantistica che cos'è la
crittografia quantistica lo vediamo con
questo video
questo qui è un video di simulazione
realizzata proprio dall istituto di
fotonica di barcellona nella quale
vediamo la stazione orbitante attorno
alla terra e all'interno della stazione
orbitante si trova un modulo il modulo
columbus
all'interno di questo modulo
è posizionato un traduttore quantistico
dove una coppia di fotoni
il sangue viene separata
contemporaneamente sulla terra in due
diversi laboratori questo caso mi vedete
tra poco barcellona e parigi
questi laboratori cosa fa lo ricevono
questi segnali e comunicano in maniera
sicura fra di loro perché la chiave
delle loro comunicazioni è collegata a
questo raggio di fotoni en tant è se
usate leghe spi a intercetta di cotone
dunlap immediatamente il segnale cambia
anche dall'altra parte rivelando
l'intrusione e quindi bloccato
la comunicazione fra i due lavoratori la
crittografia quantistica cioè la
trascrizione sicura dei dati è realtà e
l'anno scorso è stata dimostrata
praticamente in canada
e tutto questo deriva da un cambio di
paradigma che è stato incredibile perché
ha obbligato gli scienziati a
confrontarsi con delle realtà con le
quali precedentemente non avrebbero mai
avuto alcun dubbio di confrontarsi in
questa foto vediamo giorgio con angelo
che uno dei ricercatori dell'istituto
fotonico dell'istituto di ricerca
fotonica di barcellona che lavora su
questi macchinari macchinari che nascono
dalla contaminazione positiva tra la
fisica e la tecnologia e che hanno
implicazioni non solo in fisica ma in
tantissimi altri ambiti come appunto la
crittografia e per esempio lo scambio
delle informazioni
allora quando noi pensiamo alla fisica e
alla fisica quantistica con tutte le sue
leggi così strane noi le chiamiamo
controintuitive dobbiamo capire che è
necessario arrivare a un cambio di
paradigma perché altrimenti noi saremo
sempre legati a una visione già definita
e non sapremo accettare le meraviglie
della natura come questa questa è la
prima immagine che mostra la doppia
natura contemporanea della luce sia
sotto forma di particelle sia sotto
forma di radiazione elettromagnetica è
un'immagine che è stata realizzata dall
equipe di fabrizio carbone presso il
politecnico di losanna
allora per concludere questa carrellata
per farvi capire bene che cosa
significhi cambiare paradigma possiamo
anche pensare alla contaminazione
necessaria per andare oltre perché
adesso la fisica così come abbiamo visto
nelle precedenti slide
non è più solo fisica c'è bisogno che
chi studia la fisica si confronti con
che studia la biologia con chi studia
l'informatica con chi studia la medicina
con chi studia la fisiologia perché sono
tutte branche del sapere che in questo
momento devono cominciare a confrontarsi
positivamente fra di loro a creare una
contaminazione perché la nostra visione
della natura possa diventare quanto più
completa e innovativa possibile perché
come disse feinmann nel 1955
se noi non abbiamo la capacità di vedere
oltre
e difficilmente riusciremmo a
avvicinarsi alla complessità della
natura perché la fantasia della natura
supera di gran lunga quella dell'uomo
grazie
[Applauso]